antoine casubolo bonsoir êtes
journaliste vous avez entre autres
publié en 2005 aux éditions privé un
livre intitulé la vie rêvée de pierre
goldman suite à la publication de ce
livre vous rencontré deux fois un ami de
pierre goldman dénommé jean de puces et
qui vous donne un gros sac plein de
papiers de cassettes audio le fruit de
son enquête sur la mort de coluche
depuis c est mort d'un cancer en mars
dernier au moment où à l'aide de ces
documents vous commencez la rédaction du
livre qui vous emmène ici ce soir
ce livre que vous cosigné avec deux
puces et s'appelle coluche l'accident
contre enquête il aurait pu s'appeler
coluche accident ou assassinat au départ
quand depuis c'est vous parle de
l'hypothèse d'un assassinat de coluche
vous souriez vous pensez aux rumeurs la
fausse disparition d'alain colas
l'assassinât de lady di thierry meyssan
qui racontaient qu'ils aient pas eu
d'avion sur le pentagone
mais vous écoutez depuis ses parts par
politesse en fait
et puis ce qu'il vous raconte cesse de
vous faire sourire
alors on va recommencer au départ aux
circonstances du décès de coluche
mais auparavant j'accueille philippe
boggio
il est bodiot bonsoir vous êtes écrivain
journaliste auteur de biographies vous
ré édité chez flammarion coluche
l'histoire d'un mec alors coluche est
mort il ya 20 ans le 19 juin 1986
tout le monde parle d'un coluche roulant
comme un dingue sur une petite route de
l'arrière pays cannois et qui découvre
un 38 tonnes a sortie d'un virage du
[Musique]
à
en fait selon les copains de coluche
qu'il suivait à moto didier lavergne et
ludovic parisse il roulait à 60
kilomètres heure seulement
en fait dit vous antoine le chauffeur a
braqué sous le nez de coluche et coluche
voyant le chauffeur braquer braquo si la
moto se couche mais ils passent pas sous
le camion et sa tête heurte un phare
voilà ça c'est le premier point de de
votre argumentation
c'est qu'en fait comme lui je voulais
pas aussi vite qu'on a bien voulu le
dire dans les médias à l'époque et
depuis
voilà le problème il est là si vous
lisez tous les journaux qui ont paru le
lendemain et bien c'est un type qui
quitte quetta fous de vitesse de toute
façon ça on sait les papiers etc mais
qui roulait la route est sinueuse à cet
endroit là il roulait certainement à
fond il ya des petits aux automobilistes
qui disent que il a été long il se
souvient d'avoir été doublée par une
grosse moto etc
et puis au détour d'un virage il y avait
un camion qui manoeuvrait pour rentrer
dans un camping et puis pas de bol le
type il arrive trop vite et paf
il se prend mon camion qui lui barrait
la route ouais bon mois quand depuis
c'est me raconte me raconte son histoire
moi j'ai ça en mémoire ouais on a tous
en mémoire on a tous en mémoire un seul
journal un seul quotidien envoyer
quelqu'un pour enquêter sur place et
france soir
un seul hebdomadaire de toute la presse
nationale c'est le journal du dimanche
et dans le journal du dimanche
on lit ce que didier lavergne à savoir
qu' on roulait pas vite on allait à 60
c'était pas un d une route sinueuse
c'est une grande courbe et là il ya une
ligne droite qui fait 200 m avec de
l'herbe son chemin comme ça on voit un
camion arrivait au pas alors il ya trois
motos comme ça coluche et en premier les
deux autres didier ludot
le camion arrive tout doucement au pai a
pas de clignotant et au dernier moment
taf
alors pour faire quoi pour faire quoi on
a dit que ce camion ils le verront il
manoeuvrait pour rentrer dans un camping
dont déjà il manoeuvrait pas y'a pas de
campine on a dit on à lui c'est une
décharge sauvage c'est pas une décharge
c'est un prêt d'après ce camion ils
transportent des gravats pour les mettre
dans le prêt quand je fouille dans les
affaires de gens je trouve le jugement
sur le jugement il ya un truc personne
n'a lu mais ça vaut le coup d'être dit
quand même
personne n'a lu les gravats promenait de
la gendarmerie de grasse the grass donc
des gravats de la gendarmerie un camion
qui vient tout droit comme ça et paf qui
fait ça pour rentrer dans un pré pour
rouler se re pour entrer dans ce prêt il
ya une buse le petit pont on sait que
cette buse ne peut supporter que 5
tonnes ce camion fait 38
on n'a jamais vu ce camion roulait sur
sept bus même à la reconstitution jamais
fait philippe deboudt jusqu'au québec
sur le prêt et les gravats qui
proviennent de la gendarmerie de grasse
et puis surtout 15 minutes à peine après
l'accident la gendarmerie installe un
barrage sur la route avant même que les
secours soient sur place
alors ça c'est vraiment le plus
surprenant c'est jean marie marion qui a
qui arrivent cette péripétie qui est
avec dans toute une bande à jean marie
marion il ya mathilda may ils sont une
dizaine à cannes
ils sont cinq à remonter de cannes à
tokyo où se trouve la maison
bon il se retrouve au garage honda à la
sortie de cannes
ils se retrouvent la peluche didier
ludot disent oh non c'est trop long nous
on s'en va d'accord alors ils partent à
ce moment là je jean-marie et mathilda
disons-le allawi c'est vraiment de ce
trop long et donc ils disent eux ils
disent on a attendu cinq dix minutes
maxi moi je double le temps disons 20
minutes il ya 14 km ils font 14 km il y
met un quart d'heure on va dire qu'ils
vont mettre un quart d'heure ça fait
quarante kilomètres heure en moto et là
il arrive ce barrage de la gendarmerie
ça veut dire que coluche et partir
depuis cinq minutes qui a déjà les
gendarmes et les pompiers sont pas
encore arrivés c'est rapide non plein
alors l'instruction et confiée au juge
renard qui a eu maille à partir avec
eric de montgolfier à nice pour avoir
transmis des informations
confidentielles à la grande loge
nationale de france
donc là aussi un petit un petit doute
quand même sur le le juge d'instruction
est ensuite beaucoup plus grave vous
raconter que deux puces et a rencontré
un dénommé serge l'arménien un ancien
barbouze qui affirme que sa villa près
d'opio donc aurait servi de quartier
général à ceux qui préparaient
l'attentât alors voilà ça c'était tout
là tout ce qui fondait la conviction de
gens et tout ce qui l'a amené à aller
voir didier jean marie doit trouver le
jugement a étayé ce conte une confidence
alors cette confidence comment on peut
la peau
ce siège d'arméniens est mort jean est
mort sauf que jean il a raconté sa vie
et danse dans mon livre dans notre livre
je raconte sa vie il dit je connaissais
serge d'arméniens qui était inquiété lui
certains mignonne barbou je le
connaissais etc
je lui dis alors coluche il m'a dit vous
fait chier avec cette histoire
ils sont venus chez moi faire préparer
tout c'est pas de ma faute et c'est moi
quand je me retrouve avec une
information comme ça qu'est ce que j'en
fais comment je vais vérifier quand vous
talent vous disiez la rumeur mais c'est
la peste du journalisme et et comment
comment on se protège de la peste en
recoupant qu'est-ce qu'on peut recouper
ya un type qui dit je suis un agent
secret je publie une carte d'identité
dans mon nom mon lien il ya deux types
qui disent on a fait des coups on a beau
qu'on a buté des mecs on a assassiné
alors si je te dis tu me crois bon je me
dis que le rainbow warrior ça existe les
paillotes ça a existé les armes qu'on
met chez les irlandais à vincennes ça
existe et si un petit bonnet me raconter
aujourd'hui tu sais les armes à
vincennes c'est moi qui les ai mises et
tout comme enjeu le vérifier quand je le
contrôle et pourquoi ça serait pas vrai
donc ce serge l'arménien dit à deux
puces et donc que sa villa avait servi
de quartier à l'oral pour la préparation
de l'attentât contre lui c'est bien ce
que vous lisez bien ce qu'ils disent
revient et en 1988 de puces et
sympathise avec un policier de la
brigade de répression du banditisme qui
lui parle d'un dossier coluche consacré
à la préparation du meurtre
voilà il existe dossier le problème
c'est que j'en sais rien et que jorieux
j'y crois même pas ce dossier le
problème il est que j'ai en face de moi
un il ya un type qui est inspecteur à la
brb que jean a rencontré qui lui dit
hier il avait 1 indique qu'il eu
quelques temps après la mort de coluche
l'appel en pleine nuit
paniqués les morts de trouille en lui
disant on a buté coluche j'ai le dossier
j'ai tout j'ai tout et le tipi panique
etc et irak roche et j'en rends compte
donc cet inspecteur de la berbie qui lui
raconte ça il retrouve cet indic c'est
indique dit qu'il a un dossier qu'il a
eue qu'il a consultés quinze jours avant
la vente la mort de coluche qui parlait
d'un camion qui parlait de gens lui
disent de moi ce dossier ça va durer dix
ans cette histoire dix ans ou jean n'a
rien vu moi je rencontre ce mec je dis
ça y est jean est mort il est mort le 12
mars et je le rencontre le 15 ça va tu
l'as baratiner c'est bon on arrête
maintenant cette histoire
le type main
dur comme fer qu'il a ce dossier jeudi
mais c'est pas possible arrête arrête tu
l'as pas c'est pas possible c'est pas
vrai il dit écoute je lai et puis c'est
tout j'ai pas besoin je veux pas le
sortir parce que je porte ma vie ouais
d'accord
et toi tu fais ce que tu veux tu veux
l'écrire tu décris tue pas les couleurs
tu décris pas mais moi j'ai rien premier
agent et j'ai rien promis à toi je ne
sortirai pas voilà partir de là moi je
raconte les convictions de gens qui
m'ont amené à trouver ce que je dis sur
la fp ce que je dis sur les motards est
ce que je dis sur le camion ce que je
dis sur les trois hôpitaux etc etc
non mais vous alors est-ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui la conviction intime
conviction que coluche a été assassiné
je me dis que ce camion n'avait vraiment
rien à faire là bien plus que bien plus
que renault je me le dis encore plus que
lui parce que c'était parler clairement
qu'ils vivent qu'ils déchargeaient du
père years un camping c'est un camion
qui transporte des gravats de la
gendarmerie dans un pré j'espère que
c'est pareil moi je veux croire que
c'est pas vrai parce que ça dépasserait
l'entendement qu'une république puisse
alors voilà on en arrive avant de filer
la parole à abuja on en arrive aux
raisons du meurtre évidemment tout le
monde se demande pourquoi effectivement
et c'est vrai qu'il faut d'abord
rappeler que lors de sa candidature gags
en 80 coluche avait déjà été menacé son
garde du corps s'était fait repasser il
avait reçu des balles par la poste et
c'est donc déjà il avait été mis en
danger et coluche aurait rencontré jean
edern hallier
un soir ils ont un dernier lui aurait
dit qu'il était menacé parce qu'il
voulait révéler l'existence de mazarine
et c'est la seule chose que je peux dire
la manche mais c'est très bien géré
l'allier j'ai vu comment elle était
pourchassé par les services secrets
quand il voulait révéler l'existence de
mazarine accident de moto qui est dans
le vélo il ya les 6000 il n'est pas
appuyé en plus jean edern c'était pas
non c'était pas rigolo sa vie à ce
moment là étaient obligés de fuir en
italie grâce à doumeng d'ailleurs le
milliardaire rouge qui l'a aidé à fuir
vers bon alors jean-edern hallier
raconte sa coluche et coluche dit ben
moi je vais en parler sur scène ce qui
faisait son grand retour sur scène au
zénith je vais en parler sur scène voilà
ça serait les les causes
en tous les cas de cet attentat l'autre
raison c'est celle qu'avancent romain
bouteille qui dit que coluche faisait
vraiment chanter des grosses entreprises
agroalimentaires pour obtenir de la
nourriture pour les restos du coeur mais
que donc il s'est fait buter par des
entreprises d'agroalimentaire voilà
effectivement 7
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont pas
claires dans cette affaire maintenant de
là à dire qu'il a été assassiné c'est
encore autre chose effectivement de la
dir effectivement il faut imaginer
qu'ils étaient coluche en 86 il ya un
avant et un après les restos du coeur
avant les restos du coeur coluche il
s'est fait violer d'europe se fait
remercier de rêve de radio monte carlo
il ce même je remercie à la télévision
c'est un type
on y faisait salle comble les gens qui
venaient le voir qu'ils remplissaient
bobino ou gymnases etc
mais on pouvait le virer en 80 quand il
se présente et qu'il ya 16 % qui disent
avoir envie de voter pour lui
bon c'est un type après les restos du
coeur en trois mois huit millions et
demi de repas le type il devient
intouchable ce un coluche 71% des
français le trouvent sympathique
le mec qu'est ce qui pourrait arrêter
coluche 6,6 au zénith en septembre il
n'allait pas forcément balancer sur
mazarine ça j'en sais rien mais même il
balançait tout ce qu'il disait lui même
que les politiques allaient déguster que
ils avaient peur maintenant il allait
leur faire honte que tous ceux qui lui
promettaient de l'argent par exemple il
allait en parler il avait un pouvoir
incroyable c'est qu'on pouvait pu le
faire taire il était devenu quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire mais vraiment
d'extraordinaire à en juin 86 en
septembre verra pas le zénith est ce
qu'en 88 que lui n'aurait pas été aux
présidentielles qu'est ce qu'on en sait
aujourd'hui quand on demande à paul
lederman jeu les numéros télérama corps
effet coluche aujourd'hui de la
politique alors vous vous y croyez pas
un philippe à tout ça pas du tout bonnes
mais je pense mais il est né voilà je
pense que coluche est mort d'un accident
de circulation
ça arrive encore et encore des gens qui
meurent comme ça qui rend compte qu'ils
croisent un camion c'est pas de chance
et terrifiant sas a causé une stupeur
extraordinaire dans le pays
donc je comprends qu'on ait envie de
trouver d'autre explication qu'une
qu'une mort par mauvais sort mais ça
arrive encore et je crois que c'est le
cas dans cette histoire il y en a du mal
à voir mourir les eaux reconnaît mais
les ans connaît alors évidemment je
comprends que les amis de coluche qu'ils
ont pris dans leurs bras et trouvait la
réalité autour d'eux très très anormale
le chauffeur qui tendait ses papiers
vous raconter ça alors qu'il se rend pas
compte que c'est coluche mais vous
imaginez un chauffeur de camion à qui on
dit tu viens de tuer coluche l'imaginé
qu'elle
l'air il peut avoir bon donc je crois
que tout est comme ça à partir de là il
ya une sorte de fantasme qui se
développe
ça a commencé dès le lendemain de la
mort de deux de plus ça n'a jamais été
étayée et à mon avis ni excuser moi
c'est toujours pas étayé ne trouvait pas
probants le nom de tous à landorthe
parce que non non je pense que c'est un
procédé
je pense qu'effectivement il ya des
anomalies ou des bulles quand vous
faites vous même l' enquête et que ses
pales en quête d'un mort parce que ça
aussi dans un livre c'est toujours
bizarre de reprendre lankais la mort au
début quand vous parlez de la dépêche
afp quand vous parlez des gendarmes
oui je suis sûr que vous avez vérifié
que la dépêche n'est pas à la bonne
heure mais ça pouf quoi et même s'il y
avait une dépêche qui était méchamment
d'une autre heures
si les gendarmes avec consciemment fait
un barrage avant les secours ça prouve
quoi dans l'attentât par rapport à
mazarine
si on lit votre livre vraiment
sérieusement comme je lé fais jusqu'au
bout on est obligé pour étayer la thèse
de l'attentât d'additionner des
journalistes de l'afp et les
journalistes parisiens que vous
critiquez parce qu'évidemment ils ont le
premier soir ils ont raconté beaucoup de
bêtises pour le chausseur les gendarmes
les critiques les poules ps mitterrand
les gendarmes de mitterrand mais c'est
les gravats les gravats de la
gendarmerie
je pense le sujet et fait tout ça le
camp pour vous cette théorie du complot
oui c'est la théorie du complot est
vraiment keane qui tourne en rond en
plus soyez cercle et on a le choix de
l'immobile c'est un peu mazarine c'est
un peu l'agroalimentaire s'est un peu en
81 parce que il était déjà un peu
dangereux mais ils allaient être encore
plus dangereux 88
bon ça me paraît être un pur fantasme
c'est ces discussions fumeuse pour moi
et je prends également issu de la vox
populi parce que c'est ce que les gens
de la rue disait au lendemain de la mort
de coluche on a voulu faire taire
il ya aussi un fantasme autour de ça non
il ya sûrement un fantasme mais c'est la
première fois que je vous dis et que les
gens vont entendre qu effectivement le
camion ne paraît pas la route
c'est la première fois que j'en vois
autant chez les jeunes enfants
je vais finir non non je vais finir à
l'orangé finir c'est la maternelle
voilà c'est vrai je veux pas prendre le
parti d'antoine puisque le mode mais
c'est vrai qu'on a tous imaginé envoie
ce camion au milieu comme un mur de de
ferraille et coluche qui se met dans le
camion alors que les mecs qui étaient
avec lui c'est à dire ludovic paris et
didier lavergne dit c'est pas vrai régal
obligé de les croire et qui étaient avec
lui quand c'est sûr donc je reprends
c'est la première fois que je compte que
les gens vont entendre et là ils vont et
étayer leurs fantasmes que le camion
n'était pas au travers qu'ils étaient
tous droits c'est la première je
finissais revenir sur un juge runner
c'est la première fois que les gens vont
entendre que le camion n'avait pas son
clignotant et qui tournait non pas pour
aller dans une dans une décharge mais
dans un prêt c'est la première fois
qu'ils vont entendre quand même que ce
camion qui transportait des gravats de
la gendarmerie
c'est la première fois qu'ils vont
entendre des fêtes ou simple parce que
finalement je fais le travail que si en
tant qu' en tant que journaliste ya 20
ans on m'avait envoyé où on avait envoyé
n'importe lequel n'importe quel
rédacteur en chef ont renvoyé n'importe
quel journaliste le lendemain c'est ce
qui est arrivé aujourd'hui dans le
journal du dimanche au journal de france
soit il aurait ramené ce que je dis il
se trouve que là on a tous lu dans les
journaux quelque chose de faux et qui
n'a pas été corrigée alors que dans le
fantasme populaire ça soit rester mais
attend au sein de la station à moi je
veux bien sauf que moi je vous dis c'est
la première fois que je vais dire
quelque chose qui n'est pas contredit et
tu ne seras pas démenti le camion
roulait en face tout droit maintenant
pour revenir aux camionneurs j'aimerais
bien le voir le camionneur je cherche
j'essayais de le voir je suis passé par
son avocat j'ai essayé de rencontrer
j'aimerais qu'ils parlent qui nous dit
il en arriver où il habite dans le sud
de la france j'ai six des dix décidé
dans mon livre de pas citer son nom il
est dans tous les journaux ça on l'a mis
en pâture dans tous les journaux
le problème c'est que il faudrait qu'il
raconte il ya un truc qui me c'est un
petit détail mais un truc qui m'a
halluciné autant aujourd'hui je suis des
procès de temps en temps etc
j'ai relu la presse et nice matin par
l'ons qui rend compte du prêt tous les
tous les journaux qui rend compte du
procès par exemple dans nice matin
j'ai trouvé ce truc incroyable en
parlant du camionneur il ya entre
parenthèses dont on n'a pas entendu la
voix de tout le procès ça veut dire que
si je comprends bien ça veut dire que le
président en ouvrant l'audience il dit
pas monsieur levé vous expliquez nous ce
qui s'est passé le journaliste dit on
n'a pas entendu la voix
moi j'en suis là je n'ai jamais entendu
la voix de ce monsieur alors évidemment
il a tué coluche évidemment le pauvre
tout ce que vous voulez mais nous on a
le droit de se poser des questions ils
racontent immeuble parce qu'il a
petite interview dans l'événement du
jeudi dix ans après il explique qu'il a
eu les hélicoptères des paparazzi il ya
des journalistes qui sont venus à sa
porte que sa femme a déprimé que c'était
ce que je vais faire ça moi non je vais
passages demandent un rendez vous mais
là je suis c'est clair je veux dire je
le demande qui viennent nous expliquer
c'est tout simple il ya des trucs qu'on
ne comprend pas et en tant que
journaliste je crois que c'est mon
travail de faire ce que j'ai fait parce
que si si c'est un accident
alors on a tué le bouffon mais c'est
vous les bouffons et c'est moi qui fais
mon travail comme vous faites
aujourd'hui voilà c'est tout coluche
mettait toujours sans qu'à ce jour là il
l'a pas mis comment organiser avec un
camion alors on excuse moi c'est pas
vrai mais c'est pas grave c'est pas vrai
mais c'est pas grave parce que si
c'était vrai cette histoire d'un camion
vous par exemple des marais dit le
camion ses larmes vraiment pour tous les
services secrets la meilleur truc c'est
que ça passe pour un accident on va pas
mettre une balle dans la tête d'un mec
parce qu on verrait que là ce n'est pas
un accident
le camion c'est génial je vous rappelle
la sphère saint-aubin un camion qui
percute une voiture sauf que c'est pas
la bonne voiture le casque le casque si
vraiment ou décident de but est un mec
avec un camion vous croyez pas que l'on
sort foudre buts et deux autres avec et
puis en plus il était premier des fois
ils deuxième des fois l'été troisième
c'est sacrément calculé tout ça il ya
trop de paramètres mais c'est bien mais
c'est le temps de voyager de gossip
aléatoire si vous visez mondiale vous
verrez que c'est pas l'hétéroclite vous
verrez que ça s'enchaîne
non moi je les lui ça ne s'enchaînent
pas je suis désolé vous désolé
je propose qu'on lis vos de livres voilà
et je voudrais dire que le livre de
philippe j'ai lu à l'époque tout ce qui
était sortie sur le cliché est depuis et
je pense que la biographie de philippe
boggio est pour moi la définit la
meilleure est sûrement là définitive et
puis je n'envisage pas il est tellement
été proche de cette histoire là comment
aurait-il pu passer au travers de tous
les indices et éléments que vous
décrivez c'est remettre en question son
travail
et puis vous vous avez eu peut-être plus
d'éléments fâché passé là je pense que
la biographie que philippe a écrite de
sur coluche était formidable excellence
j'ai pas cirer les pompes c'est vrai
c'est ya rien à dire
seulement je crois qu'on peut je crois
qu'on peut en convenir philippe n'a pas
écrit sur l'accident il a écrit parce
que voilà il a conclu il ya deux pages
sur l'accident moi je me sens pas en
polémique avec philippe fils a un peu
l'air avec moi avant qu'il mais il va
répondre mais moi en lisant votre livre
puisque c'est la première chose que je
fais un joris du monde qu écrit on va
tout de suite allé voir surtout philippe
dit la thèse absurde de l'attentât moi
ça me fait peur donc je vais regarder
bon il dit rien il dit rien qui
contredit hier que maintenant il peut
dire je n'y crois pas mais il peut pas
dire moi j'ai enquêté sur l'accident sur
l'attentât où l'accident sur la mort et
j'ai une autre version
je ne crois pas c'est une biographie de
toute la vie moi je raconte cet accident
aux dires de degas j'aurais aimé qu'il
soit là à côté de moi c'est le seul
domaine qui le suivait et en plus c'est
pas qu'ils auraient fait plaisir à jean
depuis un milieu disent non mais ludo il
l'a encore dit dans la presse cette
semaine dit comme vous c'est à dire si
effectivement le camion ne tournait pas
il arrivait détroit et ça les audits
personne ne le serait on peut dire tout
ce qu'on veut mais personne ne
l'entendant ce soir il en compte pour la
première fois
antoine casubolo et jean de dieu sait qu
luge l'accident aux éditions vivait là
mais jo
philippe boggio coluche l'histoire d'un
mec j'ai cherché à l'arrière en madame
messieurs et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu